foutez de ma gueule
les gars je suis ravi d'avoir sa chaîne
youtube et la première fois bienvenus
c'est la millième fois bienvenue tous
merci en tout cas pour m'inviter à
plonger merci m on va rentrer dans cette
maison il ya vraiment un bébé qui dort à
les tâches et nous on doit pas faire de
bruit on va être assis à une table et va
nous arriver des apnées avant chacun
peut ni goût va tirer chacun une carte
au hasard et l'homme nous va se prendre
la pose mais attention n'oubliez pas les
tâches que se passe-t-il le bébé dort
mal au dos le vaincu leurs deux managers
et l'argent sale effectivement il ya un
baby sitter avec lui au bistrot de brest
on a un petit baby phone avec nous sur
la table ronde un temps qui passe dans
la chambre de l'enfant si jamais on fait
trop de bruit j'ai mis un peu si jamais
on réveille carrément il pleurait quand
il pleure ça veut dire que quelqu'un a
perdu si vous perdez deux vies que se
passe t on est éliminé au set face à
guéyo exactement c'est fini parce que tu
peux nous donner le bruit qu'ils me
lâchent mares non c'est un truc de fou
sa naissance il aura pas de me dire sans
moi à lucas apparemment je me sens pas
maintenant parce qu'il ya eu un débat
quand on est arrivé et il ya ce fameux
débat de l'odeur à chaque partie
persister mais je disais ce sans témoin
allez on ne s'était pas la meilleure
j'en est vrai qu'elle a trop parlé cuit
[Musique]
on a les problèmes inverses dans la vie
c'est un truc de ouf vous reconnaissez
ccoc
mécontents dont il avait pris le chichi
bilité au clocher j'en ai une et fiction
[Musique]
et les biens aux cris
vient d'achever cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par rim os chine merci à eux
j'avais fait une collection avec eux de
coop et là j'ai fait une petite
collection avec ce physique et mais
c'est disponible sur leur site aux côtés
de tas d'autres collections comme celle
de one piece harry potter jay z psg one
piece psg harry potter des mazades
laurie la haute cour
vous voyez qu'on n'y a pas de coke
mais d'ailleurs vous avez moins 10% avec
le code le bébé doors avant de passer à
la première épreuve laissez moi vous
présenter le baby sitter maxime
salut les gars relax du cam a prévenu
vous allez faire une petite soirée ici
juste pour vous prévenir je garde mon
gosse en eau que le sommeil un peu léger
pas de soucis vous pouvez parler et tout
mais tranquille quand tu travailles chez
asos
tu vas dire
toujours vous préviens à toi tu lâches
des missiles comme c'est vrai que c'est
très profitable si vous avez un
e-commerce n'hésitez pas à appeler
maxime
[Musique]
je pense que le gaz est judicieux
première épreuve c'est parti
qui veut la première carte louis qui
veut la deuxième manche le pont qui veut
la troisième jeu pour la 4e 1 2 3
il n'y aura qu'un seul vainqueur tu vas
te battre et aux comptes max bill et de
lui un petit con toi tu boxes diouf
confiné
[Musique]
élégance et de la lutte c'est de la
lutte il faut que j'aille moins de temps
faut que tu marques un territoire jeu
prise dessus comme les animaux qui
pistent gb directement un corpus la
jarrie scotto la raison il fallait
stoner 20 mètres de
moi faire un
peu de bruit ce pas non plus fermement
franchement phénomène est en train de
dire qu'aucune chanson pour nous oui il
faut que thierry jordan soutien à ses
partenaires ont vraiment au courage
[Musique]
merci bon
j'ai passé le truc
c'était donc ça se moquant encore à me
tient pas ses deux chambres ouais ouais
on admire sincère qu'on admire matelas
pour les amis jordan il a fait une
petite sieste de jouer mais ça allait le
bruit on doit baisser ou ses limites
quoi ok
lagarde premier regard tu es allé dans
l'espace
il m'a éclaté porter ya un peu nigaud
ostéopathe qui viennent pas il arrive
deuxième épreuve
squeeze deux mois la quatrième carte est
donc celle qui est maman c'est sa petite
taille que tu veux c'est ça c'est pour
moi je veux
[Musique]
lakhal celle de devant celle de derrière
seuls deux heures solidaires
[Musique]
fo et puis quand tu attends la voix
comment s'écrit pas de l'avant avec un
cas que tu veux dire tu es un petit veau
qui
avait été un peu
mis de l'avant les marchés tu va marcher
sur un cactus sûreté cactus je serais
étonné c'est quoi ce coup de mer ils
sont fous de foot
ça y est on est dans le texas où colas
et les
chérubins milan je vois pas où ça me
même tout seul puis ruhr réussit je
pense que c'est le réveil sonne on est
foutu et 8 076 samedi mec est libre
rouge empaquetées grandes jambes mais
met un pied au dessus d'un cactus à la
schlague ans à écran
tactile faisait de l'escaladé c'est ce
que ça engendre traîner
[Musique]
[ __ ] les sites
c'est impossible
à
[Musique]
crissier votre décembre
pis le tester
ça vous fait rien
donc c'est vous qui avait ramené tous
ses cactus oui c'est quelqu'un qui les
litiges la mine vous allez regarder arte
aventure non en gros c'est un reportage
qui s'appelait des statuts végétaux donc
tu as une vie en moins d'écho
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
mais frigo a été tu fais trois mètres
avec des grands doutes vous verrez j'ai
encore mal source article et cactus
[Musique]
en inde un contenu un peu de temps en
temps mais c'est l'ordre début de
l'époque trop
qui veut corriger de reprendre la
première pour la gaule et moi je veux la
au deuxième jeu de la deuxième ok on
ressentait un deux trois
pièces ils m'ont indiqué dans la
nourriture c'est vrai que c'est quoi la
victoire ne tient qu'à un film et vous
mettre des pétards dans tout
ça va crescendo mais c'est fort le
premier lutte deuxième cactus dans nos
mers troisième explosive la seconde 6e
sera vous mettre une balle dans la tête
[Musique]
frérot fait papeete le pétard ce genre
j'ai pas envie de bosser ensemble en
juin dans une vie c'est pas le bon si tu
attaques touchent le fils tu me laisses
attend maintenant laisse le film
tu lui mme c'est un capteur je connais
ce que j ai
alors cette mèche n'a pas été utilisé
depuis très longtemps et les pétards on
en construit plus de nos jours ils ont
été construits en 2008 c'est vrai
ça veut dire que ce fil est bel et bien
le fils de pétards et ce film tout
récent tout neuf battu cluj
[Musique]
d'autres séries mais
c'est quoi ce portail [ __ ] pas
d'excusés parce qu'il ya eu un peu de
bruit mais c'est parce que j'ai tout
s'est forgé la rougeole j'ai la rouge
ah oui à temps aux gens elle elle sent
bien quoi ouais mais je suis je suis dit
c'est parce que j'ai tout c'est fort
j'espère ça a pas révélé bel abbès à la
bien laver vrai tu perds une vie un et
six jours et entend dire des conneries
comme ça il a hurlé juste à vendre
maintenant fermez vos gueules quoi
[Musique]
moi je pense que les deux étaient
inquiets à l'intérieur la prochaine
épreuve la personne qui l'a on l'est
tous à baisser la garde moi je le fais
c'est moi je suis en colère contre le
bruit ou de vie ce qui doit je dois
prendre des risques je te répondrais
qu'il ya argelia cosaques et un chignon
je dois lui thierry tu regarde ailleurs
je regarde et on passe à l'épreuve
numéro 4
qui veut la première cartouche pour la
première j'ai jamais pris moi je peux
bien de cette vingt deuxième mais il y
en a une qui te fait de leur âge de
voter je pense à la peur
ou tard
ça comme ça le coût du spectre du va
devoir
m
moi je pense que tu vas devenir un
mécanicien ils vont ramener une voiture
et yakuza et je dois réparer la voiture
réparée son personnel à l'étude comme
quand on voit une voiture et là la
voiture elles rendent peut-être scooter
atemax peut-être
admet que vous faites vos jeux je
déconne
[Musique]
je dois monter un meuble qui
confieront trois volets des
[Musique]
bébés gêné du tout
où là vous allez tu fais quoi salaire
[Musique]
c'est ça le meuble on va monter ces bons
jeux mais les outils de suite j'ai caché
sous son canapé
[Musique]
je paie la notice en évidence
choix
[Musique]
je me
je
ne vous aime pas trop
ce coup ci tu dois te donner une
visite en guerre je suis large et
économique qui génère des preuves numéro
maintenant qu'on a toutes nos cartes
tout le monde passe la carte à son
voisin de droite
tout le monde échange avec son diacre
turquie l'attention vous après
deux trois rois
les affaires toujours
[Musique]
d'après il faut remettre le courant
comme dans à vos classes
[Musique]
et karoui bbox le bij proxy non ça c'est
moi
l'équipe c'est une quinzaine de bateaux
qui
[Musique]
s'est passé
il faudra lui même
lucas
tu avais peut-être un peu oublié de me
dire d'aller couper toute l'électricité
de la maison pendant ta soirée
tranquille si tu as koupèla je voulais
faire une fête nocturne l'ena il ya des
pannes lucas tu as une vie en moins mais
c'est pas beau ça je veux rien
n'attendez pas la prochaine fois vous
faites ça je vous sors tous les cas j'ai
reçu un message de yakuza puisqu'on
s'est échangé nos numéros dans deux mois
ladji amin il faut que tu te lèves et tu
sortes c'est terminé pour toi d'abord
l'aventuré foot elle lui parlait avec
les sas ont décidé d'intégrer internet
je lui parlais tient maintenant ouais tu
dis un truc comme en devient faucon pas
dedans moi j'en ai marre on a peur un
moment donné faut aussi nous sommes un
peu de caractère quand même on est
d'accord les gars mais qui tu veux pas
on attend je lance les preuves et quand
il revient tu t'expliques avec vous
reste ému là on se chauffe on laisse
plus rien passer 11 et on passe à
l'épreuve numéro 6
la première la première l au moins cela
prend je reprends la théorie de la
première et la deuxième à l'est
la transtu et la cale vas-y mon frère
fait baiser comme tout le laisse vous
vous êtes prêts 1 2 3
c'est quoi
liberto avant que sonne la fin sans
compter qu'avec du réveil auto aussi ah
bon
c'est quoi exactement
[Musique]
senes km de levés
c'est l'habitacle est pour moi jean
sala cousine envoyé en prison c'est une
seule est en
[Musique]
fait qu il faut pour vous faire il fait
comme on fera mieux
[Musique]
j'ai tapé
cas je sais ce que le faire je suis avec
vous je m'assois ont enlevé leurs
applaudissements
[Musique]
je lui proposais une co créneau chine
pour le calmer c'est quoi ce bordel
avant toute chose j'aimerais vous offrir
cette coque rhino chine il ya un code de
réduction normalement de 10% mais je
vous la donne entièrement pour jean my
phone 8 donc ça demande pas à mes jordan
vous pouvez m'expliquer là et il a juste
rapprocher portemanteau puisque big bill
il il avait un sac à dos l'un est un
casque il est venu en vélo il a tout mis
sur le faite vous avez juste envie de
réveiller le gosse quoi faire n'importe
quoi on a tout sauf envie de ça vraiment
il se mit à auch de mer du coup quoi
pardon bien sûr qu'on jordan
avec cette mélodie convient d'entendre
ta une vie embrasser sur
les intérieurs abandon j'espère que ça
pue sa race ça pue ça rappelle très bien
et c'est comme ça qu'on lance du coup là
les profits 7 la dernière épreuve
il va falloir être on échange exposé à 9
ans
en échange en diagonale
on compte jusqu'à 30 au mas carte 1 2 3
je suis sûr que j'avais rien de grave
donc de prat ar et vise le silence en
gros c'est des yakuzas devenir expert du
ferme ta gueule et je ramène balayé non
non je dis
[Applaudissements]
tu touches ottomane si je comprends bien
il ya une cible franchement non mais
t'es sur moi je pense franchement les
gars si vous mettez devant on a toutes
les chances de notre côté billy
beane pense que tu te mettes là si je la
vois que la up delattre à temps
voilà c'est prêt allez
allez la france tombe plus de la scène
du st
[ __ ] mais c'est quoi ce bordel j'étais
pas loin de la cible c'est pour ça j'ai
pas osé la dévier la faute à un besoin
je vais la mettre bien
ces gens ne me sépare du doigt la maison
donner c'est sérieux
vous êtes sérieux il était bien là il
dormait super vous foutez de ma gueule
tous tout cela vous êtes tous morts non
non vous regardez regardez regardez
celui là au vu des éléments chacun tient
dans sa main tu peux dire franchement
créeront qui ne dégagent regarde mettez
tous vraiment la gamme vous tendez tous
vos mains oui vous pouvez bluetooth ou
vraiment je me suis vu de ce que tout le
monde assure les genoux que tu peux voir
qui est le coupable vous vous levez tous
par exemple bien sûr du gala très
strictes c'est ça ou
mais c'est toi tous éliminés si vous
voulez lui n'est sûr veut dire quoi vous
barrez dès que
mon père se faire du bruit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les mecs on a tout perdu et je pense que
l'on méritait tous ensemble dans la
victoire comme dans la défaite j'ai
passé un très bon moment avec vous merci
pour ça c'était il y avait de l'acting
du début à la fin
je me suis régalé les gars après ya
parmi vous et qui j'ai un peu moins
d'affinités mais alors les deux autres
c'était un truc de balades avec plaisir
trop conscient qu'un judée regarde très
dirigé vers moi non j'ai dit en a un
avec qui j'ai eu moins d'affinités et
ceux qui le souhaitent mais je vous
quitte la gare est-ce qu'on va savoir
ton non verbal quand tu dis juste une
dernière fois c'est vrai les gars je
vous kiffe arrêter d'avoir peur je vous
kiffe blake a personne à reggane et
c'était vraiment trop marrant je passé
un bep de moments légal pleurer de rire
sénat portait beau
jeu début à la fin et spatiaux n'a pas
refait pas je vous rappelle aussi que
cette vidéo était faite en partenariat
avec rhino shield c'est grâce à eux
qu'on a pu ne pas réveiller un bébé
aujourd'hui tout le lot nos vifs
remerciements voilà donc la nouvelle
collection déco classe cloud gaming est
dispo sur leur site il ya moins 10%
pendant 48 heures je rappelle avec le
cot cot le bbd
merci à vous d'être venu pour de vrai je
passe un truc merci les gars ça m'a fait
grimper geste est très drôle
au plaisir les gars non mais vraiment
parce que même en dehors de la caméra
oui
[Rires]
non j'allais dire que même en dehors de
la caméra des bêtes de gars que je
connais ça prouve qu'on a dvd
mais c'est pas le cas de vazy les gars
je dois les arrêter ces trois là sont
inarrêtables merci à vous de faire des
vidéos on se souvient tôt sur twitter ou
sur youtube ou ailleurs j'en sais rien a
très vite merci
[Musique]